The Joe Rogan experience. Um, but like I,
I'm interested as well with this. I keep
bringing up the subject of the empty, uh,
like what
I guess while I want to know about
is like, cause I, I'm, you know,
obviously a person in recovery, I
don't drink, I don't take drugs,
haven't done for a long time and are
recognized for certain people [inaudible]
they can't do it safely.
Psychedelics and hallucinogens is,
it seemed to me exist in a real mount
side of that because they're not about,
they're not pleasure seeking. There's like
seem to me like it's a spiritual Paul.
However,
I'm a crafty bastard when it comes to
this stuff and I'm always looking for an
in, you know, when I see your
cannabis treasure trove over there.
I mean that is some, yeah, as you said,
let Raiders of the lost Ark Stuff and
I'm holding in my hand now the CBD rich
cannabis soft gels class been,
you know,
so like I'm sort of worried
that that is a gateway that CVD,
which is not necessarily
psychoactives psychoactive. It's not,
but it does help you with anxiety
and helps a lot of people because it
alleviates a lot of inflammation,
which tends to have a corresponding
impact on, on your anxiety.
I was gonna say, this says here, 11
milligrams of THC. Does that mean,
I mean it says THC. It does say that
the bonds are probably a wonder one.
This is the one to one or
ed tech 18 to one or 11.
It says there's an 1,101 is a couple
of different ones in that box. Oh,
I give you, almost give you the
wrong one. Show a bag of snack.
Don't take that. They swung,
goes back in this one.
This one's way more powerful
than the one to one.
You seem to seem very relaxed and free
from anxiety. I will say that. Um,
but like say like, oh well I suppose
I'm interested in, because listen,
I'm meditating the whole lot. I meditate
a lot. I'm doing all these things.
I'm experiencing transcendent states.
I'm experiencing what it's like to not
feel attached to my identity as Russell.
Who are you before you are Russell?
Who are you before you identify yourself
as a man in England? Who are you?
Who is the person who is the
consciousness? Who is the awareness?
And when I listened to say,
Terence Mckenna talking about
his experiences in Psychedelia,
it's such lamb and with such lucidity
and we've so many philosophical
connotations and the way that he uses
the information he's getting from
hallucinogenics, um, experiences
to speculate on how we
should organize society,
what it,
what the implications are for freedom.
He's refusal to accept that there are
certain kinds of experiences that should
be prohibited.
That it's ridiculous that adults
should be prevented from having that.
I'm fascinated by. I'm also,
I suppose part of my biases.
I love anything that gets me out of my
head. I feel a tremendous sense of relief,
whether it's through meditation or even
sport at the or sex being relieved of
the burden of the constantly thinking
mind. But when I hear like those, um,
vivid or descriptions of
DMT realm or our West Korea,
I think something in me hungers
for that hungers for it.
Do you worry that you're trying to get
intoxicated? You worry that you're,
you're trying to find a loophole.
Yeah. Cause I am doing that.
I'm Lou palm looking for a loophole.
He's like, I'm going around.
I like a so of a trash lawyer looking
for some weight gain. Is there,
hold on a second. What about this lawyer?
That's a great way of putting it. Yeah.
I mean,
uh,
I know people that have problems with
addiction that have done psychedelics and
didn't have a problem,
but I'm sure some people have had
problems and I don't know about them.
DMT is interesting in that,
first of all, it's very quick.
The experience is only about 15
minutes, 20 minutes Max. And it's also,
it's not necessary.
It's not an intoxicant in the way that
you would think about traditionally.
You are still you in,
in the face of this experience.
And I think [inaudible] I think it's
some sort of a chemical gateway.
That's what I think.
I think there's a gateway in your mind
that can lead to some other dimension
that's probably there all the
time. If they raise, I, uh,
omnipresent continually existing realm
that human beings aren't accessing
because of that particular buyer,
chemical formulation of consciousness
as it is in this point in our evolution
and that we can get there. And
it seems as if like, you know,
I've heard Terence Mckenna say
it's more real. It's more real.
They stuff in there. Yeah.
You know, and excuse me.
And when he talks about them beings,
you know,
like that he describes
herself dribbling basketballs,
creating life Faberge egg like I devices
fruit vibration and it's easy to do it.
I never saw him.
I want this called the machine elves.
He's called them all
sorts of different things.
The way I've described them as they're
the geometric patterns made out of love
and understanding. So
like, so you've read,
you can look at a geometrical
pattern and read meaning into it.
It had an emotional quality. They're
made out of something and they move,
they change.
Like they don't stay what they are.
They're constantly evolving in front
of you into something more and more
beautiful. It's very weird.
What did it make you feel like?
I knew nothing.
There was the most profound aspect,
like all of the stuff that you concentrate
on everyday is nonsense and there is
some other thing that's connected
that's probably influencing this world.
Yeah, and it's probably what people see
when they have near death experiences.
The depictions of the afterlife.
I mean that's probably what it all is and
religious experiences and when profits
are talking about, oh my God, I went
into this round. There's these beings,
they've told me we're all one.
We have scholars,
other scholars in Jerusalem or connecting
Moses's experience with the burning
Bush to the acacia tree, the
Acacia tree, which is rich and DMT.
The burning Bush is with God was to
Moses and that through this burning Bush,
he came out with these 10 commandments
of how people should live their lives.
I mean that easily could have been just
a very convoluted sort of translation of
a DMT trip. Certainly. And
also when you think of,
certainly there are archetype or images
that seem to be repeated throughout
ancient cultures aren't an archaic stories
that seem to refer to the potential
for plant experiences
to affect consciousness.
Even the garden of Eden do not eat of
the fruit of the tree of knowledge,
otherwise you will become as gods.
You know, I sent that. Now if,
if there is some realm that we
can reach through that experience,
but seeing that puts into perspective
everything that else we experiment on the
material realm and that thing seems to,
in your words,
be m and a in love and
understanding while ever changing,
completely formless and communicate
in love and understanding it for,
I can't help but think that that
should become our pri already.
To have a relationship with that realm
and to bring about that experience.
I don't even mean in a literal way.
Cause even terrorism,
Mckenna said there were some
people vulnerable souls.
He was probably referring to people like
me that probably shouldn't mess around
with that kind of stuff. Really talking
about people with schizophrenia,
which he believed he had, by
the way. Did he? Yeah, he, he,
he had some very unique perspectives
on schizophrenia and the,
the way people interact
with the world itself.
I think if we lived in a healthy world,
uh,
healthy civilization that had a
healthy relationship with psychoactive
substances, we'd probably have centers
where you would have a legitimate Sharman,
a medical advisor and someone would
take you through a guided experience.
We're doing that now with a ketamine.
There's a lot of people that are
very depressed that are having a,
these physician controlled
ketamine experiences that
have had a profound effect
on their depression.
My friend Neil Brendan's gone
through several of them and he was,
he's a comedian, a very funny
comedian. So when he was describing it,
it was hilarious.
I was going to a doctor's office,
a tripping his fucking balls off,
you know,
and the doctors shooting them up with
intermuscular ketamine. Oh my God. Yeah.
And he's having these
insane, so yeah, I go,
so you're having psychedelic experiences
like, oh yeah, that's scribing.
It was really funny. Um, I mean,
tripping his fucking balls off in
these whatever states that ketamine,
I've never experienced ketamine.
I don't know what it does,
but it's apparently profoundly a
hallucinogenic and you have these wild,
crazy experiences on it.
And for whatever reason it has a a
great impact on depression for a lot of
people.
I think it's a perspective enhancer,
but it also does something
to rewire the mind.
Some of this suggests is that mental
illness is a response to our material
conditions. Whether that's
mentally, honestly schizophrenia,
depression or addiction is like,
like people are going on and on a minute,
this is now we're supposed to live.
I took that,
came in one time towards the
end of my using and as usual,
it's not in the right type of environment
should be doing stuff like that in a
nightclub. You need to be under
that. She manic conditions,
why coke guy or whatever,
who had nominated a shaman,
but I felt like it was like going into a
tunnel made of sound and they're having
to navigate. I was like, Oh shit, I'm
still in reality. What am I going to do?
Is it is my self consciousness becomes
a noise instead a string of words
and signs. Yeah, mom in a
Gad, his place, you know,
so like for me it's clear that drugs
were never meant to be recreational.
In fact, they never was. I was never,
hey man, this is crazy. I was was like,
I'm fucking pain.
I need some shit to help me out.
Otherwise I'm can probably kill myself,
you know?
So like it was a way of
holding that stuff. Arms Limp.
So I guess my renewed curiosity around
Dmt in Iowa and Iowa Ska and other sort
of plant medicines and
like, you know, that,
do you know Daniel Pinchbeck and like
them guys are sort of part of that?
I'm curious about it cause I guess I'm
continually trying to find a way where
someone go, right, here's a way where
we can do it, where it sort of safe.
And I've heard of other
people in recovery doing it.
But when I think about
what my motivation is,
is when I hear people talking about
and my own and my own recollections of
experiencing what felt like God.
And by God I mean a sense of oneness
and that my individual identity isn't my
real identity and I'm
connected to everything.
And love is the most important thing.
You know,
I want a real experience of that
so that when I'm out in the world,
I can remember when I'm driving or when
I'm dealing with people or if I'm buying
something or if I'm feeling inferior
or feeling superior that like you said,
this is bullshit. This is like a secondary
reality. Don't let it govern you.
You know, as, as someone that's been
seduced by fame or personal life.
If I get this of film, then everyone's
going to love me. Oh. If they stand up,
set goes well.
You know,
like I personally placed all of
my wellbeing outside of myself.
There's certain knowledge that there is
an inner connection that will take care
of you. That's accessible.
I guess I'm, you know,
hungry to sort of feel it in a
way that it's like, oh my God,
now there is no doubt it's been
in a sense is a crisis of faith,
not crisis psychedelic states that you
could achieve without taking anything.
I mean, you could certainly get
there, um, in a flotation tank,
you could get there through
holotropic breathing. Um,
I've never done Kundalini Yoga,
but apparently the people that get
really deep into Kundalini Yoga,
you can literally have DMT trips.
I know I have friends that have done DMT
and have experienced DMT trips through
Kundalini, but you have to be really
dedicated. I mean, there's a lot of time,
a lot of time,
a lot of energy,
and you have to really understand the
methods and follow them to a t and you can
achieve these altered
states of consciousness that
are apparently, you know,
not from my personal experience,
but from what people tell me.
Incredibly profound. Yeah. I
mean, I've had comparable things.
I guess that what you know,
the difference between feeling something
that's that overwhelming that gives you
no choice. You know, like there's
like, it's not like in a Kundalini,
you've got to do these breaths correctly.
You've got to sit, there you go.
Try again. He had done a look
quite a bit of Delini well,
what for me it feels like
what I felt quite a lot yoga,
clea and meditatively is a cessation
of what I would call my individual
consciousness. Like, Oh, I'm
not this, this isn't who I am.
This is just a temporary experience and
all of the value systems of our world
are built upon these primal drives in
collaboration with a culture that like the
stratify people and manage people and
operates like a massive farm where it's
easier to keep people together operating
in these kinds wastes systemically.
I've sort of felt rushes of that
like a sun wordless clarity.
If you can imagine me having anything
that was wordless even for a moment and
like and in that space, you
know there there is great
pace. So I suppose get that.
What's turning me on about the,
like the DMT and Iowaska thing is that
the way it's narrow advised that there
you're going to meet characters
and stuff like that and it's,
and he's going to be plain
and beyond doubt, you know,
cause I suppose what profits do you
know like whether you know when a profit
returned from there,
whether it's the burning Bush or the cave,
they come back and they say all this
stuff that you'll take it seriously is not
real.
There's this other realm.
Start prioritizing it or you are
going to live in hell on earth,
you're going to be governed
by your materialistic drives,
your sexual drive and it's
going to imprison you.
And it turns out that they're
bright as I would like, you know,
I suppose what I'm after because I'm
partly, you know, on a superfood,
like on one level influenced by what
you're doing and how you've created your
own light, your creating your own
business and your own success. Like these,
this symbiosis of stand up
and the podcast and like,
it's become like a sort of a lifestyle
brand in a sense. Joe. Like, you know,
I'm sort of like, yeah, I don't,
I don't want to be continually
dragged in at these colors,
like working within institutions. Like,
you know, I'm over here doing a bloody,
I'm doing ballers and I'm bloody glad to
be over here doing ballers and working
with the rock. And I've got a funny
story about that if you want it like, um,
but like, uh, you know, like really
what interests me is like, can I be,
and can I dedicate my life to humorously,
communicate in spiritual information
and indeed starting to live it.
So like that. And I suppose
what that would mean is, you
know, I'm getting better,
but I'm not a person who's obsessed
with porn or sex or drugs or web, like,
you know, to become it, to
become what you actually are,
to recognize that we are all different.
Your perfect realization of you is
going to involve hun in and all of these
things that you've
created through your gift.
And that my perfect version of me
is going to involve all of this.
And not everyone needs to build sort of
empires or entertainment industries or
whatever.
But all of us are on some journey to
self actualization and realization.
There's individual as our fingerprints
and as natural as a seed turn in with
tree. And if we don't have
a way of accessing that, no
wonder with dissatisfied,
satisfied, no wonder we tie. There's
an opioid epidemic. They want to,
people are bored and angry and lonely.
Yeah.
Well,
I think what you can do is be yourself.
And what you can do is express yourself.
And what you can do is constantly
seek to improve and grow.
And you are doing those things. So if
you're saying, can I do these things?
Can I be comedic and spiritual and
what you're doing it right. So, so,
so it's don't, you're doing it, you
know, it's all just a matter of what,
whether or not your satisfied with your
progress and where you are and who you
are and how you express yourself.